DJ Acosta is one of two newzeas most
famous rappers his music went into the
soundtrack of the Arab Spring but now
he's going through hard times his
brother died a year ago as a jihadi
fighter in Syria many Canadians have
been joining the Islamic state Tara girl
fleeing poverty and high unemployment at
home Kosta too has to work odd jobs to
get through he's still struggling to get
back on his feet
at a cafe on the outskirts of Tunis MIDI
akari alias Costa and his friends spend
their time chilling waiting for
something to come along Kosta has hardly
had any gigs for two years now I used to
make lots of money depending where I
performed back then everything was
easier I had enough cash sometimes I'd
make two thousand dinars sometimes four
thousand sometimes I'd even give
concerts for free but then suddenly
everything changed in 2013 Kostas
brother Yusuf took off for Syria to join
the is terrorists then the news came
that Yusuf had been killed in the us-led
bombing raid on kobani Kosta has been
trying to deal with it ever since
a few months ago at age 34 he moved back
in with his mother Yusuf had been the
middle brother of three her mother
doesn't like to talk about her late son
it's too hard for her
the family rarely even enters yourselves
room kosta still can't understand why
his brother joined a group of Salafists
and became radicalized told I'm the
Muslim what's old mushaira SHINee so
cool in the harm we had a problem with
pictures I don't know why the machina
heche but he took all the pictures down
off the walls he even took his diploma
down done wasn't there some of his books
like these changed him this one says
that women should not show their faces
or wear makeup things like that another
religious book but Costa hasn't forgiven
his brother of course I'm furious all
this has destroyed our family and he
destroyed himself that's life
Kosta had to give up his sound studio
the only place left for him to make
music it's the room he grew up in
memories of the day five years ago he
was a familiar face in twenty ten and
eleven the Tunisian people took to the
streets to ask dictator Ben Ali but not
much remains of the hopes raised back
then the new government isn't spared in
Kostas nua toodles either
for the governor this is his brother's
death brought him a new target the
fanatics of a self-styled Islamic state
thousands of young Tunisians are still
joining the terror group DJ Kosta is
doing what he can to turn the trend with
his lyrics there's certainly a step too
honey you tumble the heart but I could
wash every human seedless defender
actually busy with my name is a bow
garlic honestly herb you on and create
the home of the will of all and hard
with our feet of our Jenny in a forum
who [ __ ] football da Costa looks for
spare parts at a car market on the
outskirts of tuners if he finds them he
can sell them again for a small profit
the trick is finding them on the vast
sook he comes every week
he scrapes by by doing odd jobs like
this one Gotye school Messina learmont
Ananda brassica come on you have to get
here really early and some people can't
so I tried to find the part for them and
I get money for that money they would
have had to spend on the trip here or
they might have had to pay more for the
part in a shot but I get it instead if
he finds the party's client ordered
he'll earn a couple of euros that'll buy
him cigarettes and a coffee with his
friends that's all but he leaves the
souk empty-handed the next morning cost
arrives at the culture ministry in Tunis
to present a project he's been working
on since his brother Yusuf died he'd
like to hold the workshops for young
rappers so they won't be taken in by the
radicals
he wants the ministry to finance the
project then he might be able to start
earning something again but he doesn't
have an appointment dinner at circa I'm
covering to silk level 20 I hope I can
meet the minister I already know what
she'll say okay we'll see or something
like that but it's really important to
get this project up and running quickly
because of the terrorist threat you know
don't worry she's not going I look at
guys like these and picture one of them
disappearing like that every day but
caster doesn't meet the minister as it
happened he's in the wrong place he's
directed to the office for music and
dance he waits for a full hour mandar me
or do you address the bosses madam or
Mademoiselle we always say madam okay
okay good little bit
finally Kosta is asked in but without
the cameras
a few minutes later Kosta re-emerges but
the news is not good let's go I'm gonna
say mr. blah blah blah blah nothing
happened just the usual ministry
double-talk she'll have to think about
it she's worried that I'm too radical
what full report to work another
disappointment cost her heads back home
in the taxi he lets us anger fly the
driver listens patiently
let's say that whoever you know they
refused to work with me because my
brother was a terrorist but that doesn't
mean I'm a terrorist I was always
against his views do you think I wanted
him to become a terrorist I never wanted
him to go to Syria I went to the police
a thousand times and said talk him out
of going to Syria and they always told
me oh he won't go
the day ends like most others and cost
his life in the cafe with his friends no
option to ever won't you oh la liga's it
over only one of them has a steady job
this year form of Lewis who former
former head of a mile for much I used to
have cash and lots of concerts I was
famous and now I have nothing left since
my brother's death I've been having
trouble I used to work a lot and not sit
in the café all the time and now I just
sit around here all day mama kawamura's
on my field I don't scold a visitor for
mr. well do you see these guys here
maybe they'll end up going to the is ask
them if they have guns wouldn't they go
to the is because they see no future
here and hate their lives I'll be the
first one to go I swear to you back they
live much better than we do here
I mean I'm little Emily know every time
to do it i'll be done through crowd they
believe they can make their dreams come
true with the is that they'll get a wife
a car in a steady wage shield eh i'm the
daughter who care about iris will sorry
Helman TL DR VV nah man I pack up the
wife and the car and bring them back to
Tunisia he meant it as a joke but it's
symptomatic of the boredom and
frustration that many young Tunisians
here feel they've all but given up hope
for a better future for themselves or
their country Kosta is even considering
giving up his music
five years after the Arab Spring people
in Tunisia are still waiting for a new
beginning
in the
I